i know we've made multiple reviews on
the m1 macbook air that pack
a ton of detail but since then we have
done
a lot more testing and a lot of new
devices have come out
both from apple and other manufacturers
so in this extended
final long-term review i want to focus
on what's changed
both in my personal experience as well
as the market
coming from nine months ago to now and
talk about if it's still worth buying
the m1 macbook air
now that we're more than halfway through
2021 and with rumors of the m2 models
coming out
and if any of my spec recommendations
have changed
which they have and we'll talk about
that it's getting close to nine months
since apple revealed their m1 air and in
that time it went from the most
underwhelming m1 mac to one of the best
for a few reasons
it started out as a budget laptop for
those people
who can't afford the macbook pro mostly
because
of the lack of cooling system and we
didn't really give it much attention
until we started putting it side by side
against the pro
and then it started to shock us now yes
in synthetic benchmarks it clearly was
slower
especially with lower graphics
performance because of that 7 core gpu
compared to the a core
and in our initial test we found that
the macbook air thermal throttled very
quickly
going down from 3.2 gigahertz to 2.7
and then after a few more runs of
cinebench down to
a very low 2.35 gigahertz and
after the full 10 minute run it lost
over 15
of its performance which is definitely
disappointing and that confirmed my
speculation
that this machine was only made to come
in at that low
999 dollar price tag but as you know
i was really really wrong and now after
nearly nine months
apple's least expensive laptop is now
even
cheaper and for me and many others it
keeps getting
better and better which is insane in
that time i
also realized how you can really tell
which tech products are
the best and are worth spending your
money on
here in the office we have a huge
selection of products from macs to
windows pcs
and lots of ipads and smartphones i also
have every m1 product that apple makes
including the mac mini an imac and then
one macbook pro and even
two m1 ipad pros i also have intel max
like my 16 inch macbook pro so i can use
any product that i want to
and what is crazy is that after all of
this time
i keep picking up and using the m1
macbook air
apple's cheapest mac at least from the
ones that i own
yes the m1 macbook pro is technically
better
with more powerful graphics and other
features so why is everybody
including professionals ignoring the m1
macbook pro
in favor of the air if we're judging off
of sales
and why does my pro just sit there
collecting dust
well there are multiple reasons the
first one
is definitely the price anything priced
under a thousand dollars sounds much
more reasonable to buy
compared to just over a thousand dollars
even if the 1200
pro does offer extra hardware better
battery life extra features and
performance
but with that the air didn't stay at
that 999
price tag for long as soon as people
started finding out
just how good this machine really is big
retailers started dropping the price
at first by 50 and then amazon dropped
it by a hundred dollars to 899
and just recently over the 4th of july
weekend it briefly dropped to 849
which is insane how is apple able to
make a machine
that smokes 12 to 1400 or even more
expensive windows machines
and then be able to sell it at under 900
bucks
well that is thanks to the mass
manufacturing of the m1 chip
and putting them into lots of devices
instead of previously having to pay
intel for their pricey processors
that kept overheating in their last
macbook air and had
way worse performance on top of that
even at msrp
and although the m1 air does thermal
throttle as i mentioned
it is nothing like the previous intel
models not only because it's fanless so
you don't have a fan that gets loud and
annoying
but also because it is just so much
faster that many tasks don't need as
much cpu power to perform
for example video editing or web
conferencing
and because many of those tasks have
dedicated chips to speed them up
because of that in real world use i
never once wished that i grabbed the m1
macbook pro
the m1 air is so fast that i didn't even
need my 16 inch macbook pro
for the extra graphics performance and i
am not the only one i know
multiple people that ditch their much
more expensive
larger macbooks for these m1s for
serious productivity work
which is something we would have never
believed we could do
just one year ago you do get a smaller
display which some people do prefer
but you also get so many benefits one
huge one being
battery life over the last nine months i
have thrown
almost everything at this fanless
machine
even in pro photo and video editing and
i have the base 999
model that you can buy for as low as 850
using the link down below in the video
description now yes
i have had a choke on me multiple times
but it was for one
very specific reason that is a very easy
fix
which would be my biggest recommendation
after using this for nine months
and we'll talk about that in just a bit
as far as that battery life it is
insane i went from about two and a half
hours of 4k
video editing with my 16 inch macbook
pro to almost
8 hours with the m1 air and unlike
windows laptops it doesn't slow down
when it's unplugged
i have literally never experienced such
freedom when video editing on the go
now sure my 16 inch macbook pro was good
since it retained its performance when
it's unplugged
but i still had to worry about battery
life and when i would have to plug it in
to recharge
but with these new m1 machines you don't
even have to worry about bringing a
charger with you
by now you know that we lean very
heavily on buying the air over the pro
but what about the two biggest reasons
that people say
it is worth buying the pro for well the
first one
is better battery life and yes it's true
in real world use the pro can play back
video
for about five extra hours and about two
extra hours of productivity
but to be honest that has never once
been a factor
because once the battery life is good
enough and it can get you through a full
day
the extra hours doesn't really mean much
and the other reason
is performance both because of thermal
throttling and having
one less graphic score so how much has
that
mattered in the last nine months well
as you saw thermal throttling is
definitely an issue and the graphics
is also weaker but to me it didn't
matter
at all and that's crazy because i care
about performance
that's because when you're looking at
benchmarks you see all of the
differences both big and small
and a fifteen percent difference is
fairly significant
because we were used to seeing between
five to ten percent improvements year to
year
but in real world performance what
matters most is if the machine is fast
enough
or if it isn't in certain cases 15 of
extra performance can make or break a
machine
but with the air it handles most tasks
just as well as the pro
and even though it does take a little
bit longer to export your projects you
don't really notice that in the real
world
and actual productivity and timeline
performance when you're doing the work
it is just as fast so because of that i
have never felt like having to grab the
pro
over the air not only that but the
macbook air has a
secret weapon to make it even faster
than the pro for those of you guys that
absolutely need the best performance
and here is how you could do it to your
macbook air as well for only 30 bucks
we bought a few thermal pads on amazon
and installed them which takes less than
20 minutes even if you're being very
slow and careful
and this will draw heat from the chip to
the aluminum body
so it's not the chip that's just getting
hot and holding all that heat
not only does the performance boost
significantly but it's actually better
than the pro which has a fan
because apple keeps the fan running low
until that m1 chip is really hot
this also keeps your m1 chip running
cooler for most tasks which is great for
longevity
and it can't be bad for since there are
temperature limits in place
the only downside is that the bottom can
get hotter
but unless you're running tons of
constant exports or benchmarks
for most cases you don't actually notice
it because the cpu doesn't have to run
at a hundred percent now we did remove
ours to keep testing fear
but even though my performance has
dropped back down to stock it doesn't
matter once again because it's still
super fast
even for heavy use in fact i recently
had somebody ask if they can get by with
an m1 air until the m1x max came out
and i said yes definitely as i have many
times
but the crazy thing is that once he
tried the new air
he said he doesn't even need to wait for
the m1x because it handles everything
more than good enough so he just might
not even need to
buy one and although i'm super excited
about these more powerful chips since
the m1 kind of sounds like old news now
and everybody always wants newer bigger
and faster things
for most people that one chip is more
than fast enough even in a fanless
machine
and although it might just seem boring
to buy something that's been out for a
while
for 899 or maybe even less go ahead and
give it a try i think you'll be shocked
by how well it works yes the m1x
macbooks will be great
but because of how good the macbook air
is it will still be the number one
laptop after those come out just like it
is
right now after nine months of being on
the market
usually amazon's top seller list for
laptops is just filled with super cheap
laptops
but this thing is number one in the
charts and the other colors are close
seconds with other machines being
distant from it like the macbook pro
so after nine months the macbook air is
still setting
record-breaking sales records and
premium windows laptops can't even get
close in sales performance and now even
price
what really proves this point is when we
compare the air to two brand new surface
laptop fours
with powerful amd processors and also
intel's latest
although the amd processor had way more
raw performance
when it came to real world use the
macbook air smoked it which is crazy
and it also comes in at a much lower
price and has better hardware overall
and that has been the case with every
single windows laptop that has come out
ever since this m1 air hit the market so
it's just getting
better compared to the competition the
display is fantastic
beating out windows laptops that cost
much more and the same thing goes for
the speakers the keyboard and the
trackpad
the build quality is great and the ports
are thunderbolt 4 so they could be split
into three thunderbolt ports for each
one
at a fairly low price and as i mentioned
at the start there were multiple times
where i actually had
this m1 macbook air choke up and i was
wondering
what is going on with it why is it being
so slow and this seems to be a bigger
deal with the m1 chips
than with the previous ones but
thankfully this is a fairly easy
issue to fix that was because the m1
chips rely
on fast ram and when that eight gigabyte
in my case with the base model fills up
it uses your ssd which is also very fast
but if your ram is full and your ssd is
close to being full
then one chip really seems to slow down
especially when you're doing heavier
tasks because of that
if you fill more than 200 gigabytes of
your ssd
make sure to either get 16 gigabytes of
ram or the 512 gigabyte ssd model and
then you'll have no
issues at all so after nine months the
m1 macbook air is
only getting better and better with
software being updated
and the new competition not really
bringing anything else
windows laptops can't catch up in
performance or price
and even apple's own m1 ipads were kind
of
a bit of a miss not only because of the
prices that went
up and also you're being forced to pay
for 16 gigs of ram
if you need more storage but also
because of ipad os 15
which in general everybody says that was
kind of a miss
and because of that more people are
switching over from windows computers
other higher end macs
and even ipads to just buying the good
old m1 macbook air
where the value keeps just getting
better and better
so after all this time i love this
machine and is the one that i pick up
even though i have access to
so many other macs and ipads and even
windows machines
it just handles everything even for
higher use and for students or regular
people
it is just such a fantastic deal
which is something we never thought we
would say it would come from apple
where we're used to high prices it's
cheap it is amazing and it's going to
last a long time
so thank you guys for watching if you
want to subscribe click that button
above and you can help us reach our goal
of a million subscribers before the end
of the year we have links to the best
deals
down the video description check out one
of those vids there this has been max
and i'll see you in the next video